i'm running on some processor and the
program all of the memory of that
program is stored externally in some
untrusted place could be internally in
an untrusted place but we're not
trusting the memory
and uh we want to protect this memory we
want to make sure that even though the
the adversary has access to this memory
and access to data pattern doesn't learn
anything and orm is a way to do that
it's a compiler that takes the program
and sort of modifies it a little bit
it's going to actually run the original
program whenever the program wants to
read some location in memory this
compiler will actually translate it into
a bunch of uh other read and write
instructions that's going to actually
execute
and it's going to do it in such a way
that even if you see the access pattern
you see these instructions you're not
really learning anything about these
instructions you're hiding the access
pattern here the actual physical access
pattern
okay so that that's the basic or i'm
saying of course you can also do write
and you're just going to execute the
program with this oram compiler that's
going to provide security
uh but often the way we think about um
about this type of model
is that um
is that this memory is actually stored
on some sort of a cloud server some sort
of an external you know you're storing
it in the cloud and the cloud server is
not just memory it has more it can do
computation maybe you can leverage that
so um
let me just uh before i go there tell
you a little bit about what we know in
this model so this is just summarizing
what a length told you so usually the
way we measure efficiency in this model
is just uh
we want to say for each one of these
operations the logical operation of the
program is doing how many
actual uh logical or physical operations
uh
doesn't get translated into i'll call
that the d that's the overhead and we
can get uh log n overhead with
sufficiently large block size that's
using the pathogram scheme that elink
told you about and in fact we even have
a lower bond the uh by gold rack and
ostrosky that tells you that in some
sense is the best you can hope for and
by the way this lower bound has there's
a bunch of caveats in that lower bound
so you should take it with a little bit
of grain of salt but at the very least
we don't know how to do better in this
model
okay so at least that
so i want to move into a slightly
different model we're uh again motivated
by the fact that we're really thinking
of this memory as being on some sort of
cloud server
remote cloud server and here the server
can perform useful computations that's
the difference we replaced uh the memory
before with with the server now
and probably the memory would be inside
the server but i'm just gonna inside the
box but i'm just gonna show it outside
on the picture
okay so what can we do here uh so the
first thing we can do
is that now instead of
the overham just being a sequence
translating a read instruction to
sequence of read and write instructions
to this external memory it can do a more
complicated protocol and have the server
do some of that computation that's the
main idea
and of course the server is going to
read and write to memory but we don't
have to like send each one of these
instructions directly to the server
you don't have to send it
explicitly
okay
so uh the talk is roughly in three parts
so in the first part i'm going to show
you how to leverage this model
to do an oram where the communication of
our heads so that's actually the
communication of this link per operation
is constant
not logarithmic so we're shaving the
lock factor
okay previously to sort of do lock
logarithmic uh communication or
logarithmic multiple times the
communication would have for each
operation we're going to shape that off
in this model
in the second part i'm going to actually
talk about interaction i want to reduce
the amount
what is the constant that is hiding in
this particular uh
actually i think could be as low as two
uh that's actually not if you make the
block size big enough so that that's the
that's the you know that's where you
have some flexibility but that can be
saw
exactly so so the block size will be
power logarithmic it's not going to be
that huge uh it's not going to be an
entire memory yeah we're not gonna cheat
that much we cheated a little bit
um good point
okay uh so this is about the
communication complexity in the next
time next uh part of the talk i'm going
to tell you about the um the round
complexity i want to make this actual
whole process interact non-interactive
so if you look at it there's sort of two
sources of interaction here so first of
all this protocol could be interactive
like there's interaction going on here
each time the program wants to read a
location that's one source of
interaction so you could ask to remove
that but we're going to be more
ambitious there's another source of
interaction here that's maybe even worse
which is each time the program reads a
location you have to do some interaction
with the server
right and so we're going to get rid of
all of that and just have complete
non-interactive solutions so you take
the whole program somehow
send it over to the server in some
hidden way garbled way
and the server will be able to run it
so there's completely non-interactive
you just send the program the whole
program to the server server doesn't
learn anything
okay so completely remove interaction
this is called garbled ram
uh why is the server we don't know the
output so in this case actually i'm
going to change the problem a little bit
and let the server actually compute the
output himself if you want to hide it
you can always encrypt so that this is
straight strictly better if you can do
this you can also hide output i'll i'll
talk about that
that's i am changing it a little bit
good point
uh so these are a little bit
incomparable in the first part i'm gonna
get rid of uh communication complexity
reduce that and the second part actually
the communication complexity will be
maybe worse than the first part or still
poly logarithmic there will be overhead
but we're getting rid of round
complexity
and the third part
i'm going to talk about the syncarbogram
i'll just mention it a little bit
and it's going to be pretty much the
same model as the second part but
everything will be incredibly succinct
so this uh
value here that the client is sending to
the server just depends on the code of
the program it doesn't depend on the
running time or anything like that so
you're drastically removing the
communication you're not even doing you
know one operation per read access or
anything like that
so i'm going to call that that's the
same model but a lazy client he doesn't
execute it she doesn't execute the
program herself
okay
so let me start with the first part low
communication orams i'm going to
describe a scheme to you called
anianoram
uh this joined work with chris fletcher
lynn grant serene devadas martin van
dijk and ellen g
and the idea is we're going to have an
overramp where the communication
overhead per data access is just order
one so we're shaving the login factor
but uh as rafi mentioned we will need a
sufficiently large block size there will
be some poly law again
but uh i think something i don't
actually know the exact polylog may be
locked cubed or something like that uh
but uh we are
it doesn't need to be big enough
and this client and we also don't want
the server to just you know have to do
the whole computation or something like
that have to read the entire memory so
the server computation and the client
computation still poly login
okay so the main thing we're improving
those the communication
and uh we'll show how to get security
even against a fully malicious surfer so
active attacks will be interesting too
and the whole thing will rely on
additively homomorphic encryption for
uh various reasons specifically the dom
guard your crypto system or you can use
somewhat homomorphic encryption but we
don't need very heavy like fully
homomorphic encryption tools
okay so let's start with some initial
ideas what's the main idea of how to do
this
what's the
adversarial model what is the server
trying to do it's the same as oram so
the server is trying to learn something
about the access pattern
so actually the the the property we'll
want is that the server doesn't learn
anything you can simulate the view of
the server
server gets zero information here
what are the instructions
read and write
you said that server is doing
computation
right what computation is that well so
let me go back actually to this picture
so uh
the server seeing is interacting in this
protocol the client's goal is to do read
and write instructions to like read the
ith bit or write the i block bit to
memory so the client's goal is the
regular oram setting but instead of
directly translating it to a bunch of
reads and writes on the server we're
going to translate it some protocol
and the security is the same though as
as in oram server shouldn't learn
anything
yeah
yeah so i call it oran with server
computation serrated or and there's
yeah many names sorry and i do want to
say it's been considered people have
considered this before in several works
using the server to leverage something
yeah i think constant actually
comes the number of rounds
whatever the sport of beats and constant
rounds
right so you want to get holy log and
you will get so yeah you want to get a
blog of size b bits which which is power
log and your your communication will be
2b order b
with constant rounds yeah
um okay
so let's do an initial idea and one idea
is why don't we just use so forget about
orm altogether use private information
retrieval or fhe so here um the client
would just send um an encryption of the
of the
bit that he wants to read or the
location on the memory that she wants to
read and we'll just run peer and get
that back to the client
so the bad news about that solution is
that here the server's work is as big as
the entire data order of n where n is
the data size so that's bad we still
want the service work to be poly
logarithmic we don't want to go
to this setting and also even if you
actually want to do this you have to
think about it a little bit you do need
a pier where you have or an fhe which is
constant overhead so when you want to
download when you're doing a pr and the
block size is b your response is just
order of b bits
and some some peers have that but it's
not trivial it's not a generic property
of beer so you will need something
special here
but for my fridge you can always get it
right
no not directly not generically actually
if you think about fhe each bit is
encrypted separately so for each bit you
have at least security parameter
overhead on the response on the response
on the on the computed value you can get
so
that and that's what i care about
yeah so it's not generic i don't know
how to do this directly from fh
just a comment so this marrying of uh uh
oram and peer
also
plays a role if you consider peer
writing
well for this writing you can actually
do even information there is a writing
by cooking some
oral insights appear writing and
something related right good so uh so
here i mean i guess if you're allowing
the server to do auto event work you
could actually do writing with fhe as
well but the main thing is we want to
somehow get rid of this sort of vent
work and like rafi said the solution
will be to somehow marry orem and pierre
so we're going to do fhe or not
necessarily fully homomorphic encryption
but some homomorphic encryption over
oram i want to say that there are
previous works that have thought about
this i'm probably not including all the
citations
um but the idea is instead of having the
client manually move that around on the
server the client is going to instruct
the server on how to move the data
around under fully homomorphic
encryption i'm going to tell you exactly
what i mean by that but that's a high
level idea
so if you remember this is the picture
of the trio ram or the path of ram
either one
so i'm drawing the tree the other way so
if you were tilting your head before now
you have to untilt now you can untilt
and
so the main invariant here is that we
have some data blocks residing in a tree
each block is mapped a particular leaf
and each block must be on a path
from the root to that leaf
okay so um
that's the that's the main that's the
data structure it's stored on the server
and it'll be useful for us to actually
separate that into two components think
of these data structures consisting of
data which is the actual block values so
these are sort of large block values
that are in these in these buckets that
are residing the tree and also um
all right some metadata
which uh which is small and the metadata
would be the block address like the
address of the block that's in this
position what leave it is assigned to
and things along those lines
okay great thanks
and also the position map so the whole
position map we can think of that as
metadata it doesn't depend on the block
size for example
okay
so how does this trio rm work well i
want to think of it as separating it
into two types of operations so there's
the operations on the metadata which are
things like using the
position map to find which
which uh leaf a block is assigned to
uh or things like reading all of these
addresses of the blocks on a path so you
know exactly which blocks are there okay
so those are the types of things you're
going to do on the metadata just read
all of it
and on the data intuitively what you
want to do is somehow move it around in
an oblivious way okay so you might want
to either obliviously read a particular
block like i want to read this block but
i don't want to reveal which block on
the path i'm reading
or i want to actually move blocks like
down the tree without revealing where
i'm moving them okay so that i'm moving
around obliviously and the way we did it
before or the way the trio ram or
pathogram or any of these schemes do it
is just by downloading the whole path
and moving them around manually
okay and that's what we want to get rid
of
so first of all the metadata
we're going to just be able to read it
and write to it manually we're just
going to do the same thing we did before
just read all the metadata all the time
and the nice thing is because the
metadata is small this is independent of
the block size so yeah it's polylog and
communication to do that but if i make
the block size big enough this is order
of the block size
so this is much less than the size of
one block and by the way i should just
mention making the block relatively big
makes sense in a lot of practical
situation like if you have a file system
the files are reasonably big
so
you want a download file you want to
download a large block
having a large blog is not a big deal
okay
no matter that i'm going to do the same
thing i did before i'm just going to
read all of it once i read the meta that
i know exactly where i want to move data
around and i know which data so during
gary for example i know exactly which
data block i actually want to read i
want this one
right i already know the address there i
know that's the one i care about
and so to do the operation on the data
i'm just going to use it with i'm just
going to do it with homomorphic
operations so previous i would just read
all of it that would be b log and work
where b is the block size
now with something like fhe or we'll see
we don't actually need fh
but um with some homomorphic computation
this will be just on the order of the
block size
again previously was because it was a
festival exactly like to read this block
i needed to hide which one i'm reading i
needed to read the whole path
yeah
the number of trees
so the number of trees remember the
other trees are storing addresses so the
whole recursion the whole that all of
that is independent of the block size i
uh i'm thinking of that as metadata all
the other trees are metadata only the
top three is data
okay so with fh this can be just on the
order of the block size
but do we really need fhe
so the hope will be to get rid of it so
let's see what do we need to do we need
to do some sort of homomorphic select we
have these k blocks think of these as
the values on a path and the tree so k
is something logarithmic in end poly
algorithmic
and we want to select one of them like
the eighth one
okay either we want to select it because
we're reading it or we want to select it
because we want to move it to some other
location
so how would you do it how would you
implement this operation so option one
is with fully homomorphic encryption i
can just encrypt the index i to the
server
and the server can do this computation
that computes the encryption of the
block eye
different than generic fear
uh yeah with pure you can do this okay
so with p i'll tell you in a second but
yeah so with homomorphic with fh or pure
you could you could do this
and you will get encryption of block i
one uh so one difference with pier is
that the number of blocks is actually
not that big it's still logarithmic okay
i'm just trying to shave that factor so
one other thing you could do this is a
little different but here we're gonna do
we're gonna use homomorphic encryption
that supports just one multiplication
okay so what can you do
that's a concrete
yeah it's a concrete pier
the main difference okay maybe i'll tell
you now the main difference is i also
need to compute again on the peer output
so i do so we'll see that's the
difference that's really why pure is not
good enough
but so this is a concrete you can think
of as a concrete pr can just encrypt
bits for each location
these are sort of much smaller
ciphertext than the whole block so i
have k ciphertext but i'm thinking of
this whole case ciphertext is being much
smaller than one of these
so i can communicate that that's not
that's not a lot of communication
i can give these to the server and then
the server can just multiply this uh you
know can multiply these values and sum
them up and get the encryption of block
i so this just requires an uh
homomorphic encryption with one
multiplication many additions
okay one multiplication method additions
are still
multiplications are hard let's get our
multiplications all together so you can
do that we can do it with no
multiplications the same thing the only
difference is that now i want to think
of this value as not an actual
encryption even though it is an
encryption i want to think of it as a
plain text value that i'm multiplying
into this ciphertext so it's sort of a
scalar multiplication rather than a
ciphertext multiplication
and i can do that the only difference is
that at the end i get an encryption of
an encryption of block of i because i'm
treating this internal encryption is
just data
right as a plain text value
and so that's why this scheme is called
onion oram we're sort of going to be
increasing the levels of or onion layers
of encryption under which the block will
be encrypted
this is a regular pair
this is a regular you're retrieving
an encrypted value exactly so that's
what benny said so the only thing is
it could be a different e so there's a
regular pier the only thing is we will
need to perform these homomorphic
operations iteratively so when i move a
data block when i do this select i'm
going to say okay take whatever output
you get and put it in this bucket
later on i'm going to have to move it
again each time i move it
i'm going to have to do this operation
so i'm going to have to take the outputs
of this operation and again perform the
same operation on them i'm going to
perform this select iteratively not just
once that's the main difference with
beer
okay and you can do that just the
sort of layers as you do it the layers
of encryption will grow the number of
layers will grow
so the question is how many times do you
do you have to do it
so let's go back and see how many times
are we moving things around
well
previously when we are doing evictions
and this is true for either patho ram or
tree or m doesn't really matter
you were always evicting blocks from
sort of higher up to lower down okay you
were moving blocks from high up in the
tree to lower down in the tree
so that's fine that sort of seems like
the layers of encryption are just
increasing at each layer of the tree
because you're always moving things from
here to here you're just adding another
layer
but the problem is you also had to evict
sometimes the block stayed in the bucket
it was in
you were moving the blocks around
sometimes you couldn't move it anywhere
it had to stay there
whenever that happened you would
increase
the layer of encryption
without moving the block lower down and
there was no bound on the number of
layers you could eventually incur this
could happen many many times
and that way you would get a lot of
layers you would eventually the just
this encrypted blog would get too large
it wouldn't be constant overhead
so the main thing here is to have a new
eviction strategy which is sort of a
variant of the previous ones but it
guarantees some sort of steady progress
the data blocks cannot stay in the same
place during evictions they always move
down whenever you touch a plug it moves
somewhere it moves down the tree
and this ensures that we can bound the
number of layers
of encryption that you get on each block
by login or order vlogging
okay
yeah so why not just after you touch
every node login times download it
re-encrypt
staple the layers encrypt was only put
it back and asymptotically it's not
going to make any difference because you
do it every say login times uh we are
going to do that essentially but uh
you're not touching just one block at a
time
to get rid of the problem of this
nested encryption you can just say okay
when it grows too big the next thing
just
strip all the layers in one shot and you
have to be a little careful because you
don't want to leak to the server with
which block has none fixed it the fixed
time right every local steps i strip all
the layers but actually so in each
operation you're adding login layers to
many blocks right because you're moving
many blocks down so it's not clear how
many you'd have to download because you
can download only one each time you
don't have enough bandwidth to download
more than one but you're adding
layers to multiple blocks
are you seeing every login type i access
the same path the packs will overlap so
so it's hard it's not well defined what
does that mean
so also rafi the thing is that every ev
every operation i'm touching at least
log and i'm adding a layer to log in
blocks but every operation i can strip
off a layer from only one block
so you that's not do you see the problem
i'm adding i'm adding an a layer to many
blocks every every one i touch on the
path but i can only strip off one from
one block
let's say there is some node which has
between you know 10 logan and vanilla
again layers already then this
falls elements in that node
then it's you know whenever you reach
this condition
go
but how do you know there's only one
maybe during an operation you suddenly
have login notes of this type right
whenever any node reaches this condition
it's a sick patient go and uh good but
you might have to cure two menistic
patients right so the communication will
get the point is that i i want to make
sure i'm only curing one i can only do
this on one patient in each read
otherwise i'm downloading too much
maybe let's uh let's continue offline
the service is how much it grows right
it seems yes yes that's not hidden
information
by the server right so okay let's take
it yeah let's take it offline so but
you're right we're actually going to do
something like that only on the on the
bucket layer on on the leaf layer so in
the leave layer you know there's nowhere
these blocks can go so they do have to
stay there they will incur additional
layers and we will actually download
manual and strip off these layers
exactly what raffi said on the leave
layer but we're bounding the the number
of values for which we have to do that
just to the ones at the leaf layer
yeah
doesn't the circuit overran that elaine
described before have this property uh
so link can you maybe link and answer
that
um
yeah i'm not sure so so the variant is
not a huge variant so so let me just say
it's not a huge variant from prior
schemes it's an eviction strategy along
the lines of what was done before but
there's subtle changes that need to be
made and
also in the analysis but you also need
to make sure that when you add layers
each layer adds additive overhead not
multiplication right perfect so i think
so so two two bullet points uh and i'll
say it so uh so this ensures that we
have log n onion layers
uh on on each ciphertext or at most
login onion layers on each hypertext we
wanna make sure that log and onion
layers only increase the ciphertex size
by factor of some constant like let's
say at most two so we need to be very
careful as evgeny that so this is great
great interactive talk uh we need to be
very careful with ciphertex expansion so
we need to make sure that if you add log
n onion layers of encryption you only
increase in order one expansion so this
means that each layer can add very
little like an additive amount it cancer
for example just even double the size of
the cipher text that would be too much
because two two times you know two to
the log n is n right so
um and this is achieved by the dumb
guard you're a crypto system
could you replace layers with just the
degree that it supports exactly yes
so this would so also this strategy is
useful if you have somewhat homomorphic
encryption where the somewhat isn't that
big
okay
so i want to say a little bit about uh
active security as well yeah
the the client sends that to the server
so let me know
each recursion step
so this client will send this vector of
encryptions
how many are there just the number of
blocks in the path that i'm reading so
there'll be logarithmically many of them
but these are small these are just bits
okay
so they're much smaller than the block
size so these login encryptions are just
don't that too much overhead
computes
no no no it doesn't matter what the
recursion layer is here i'm treating
these blocks as plain text so i don't
care how many layers are on them i'm
just going to add one more layer when i
do this
so like for eviction i mean you have to
figure out all kind of things
how do you just get away with just
figuring out one block to work on
oh good yeah i am going to need to do
this for each block i'm moving
so i'm going to do this log n time i'm
going to send log n vectors like that
not just one that's a good point for
each each block in the path i'm moving
but that's still again these vectors are
small so if the block size is big enough
poly logarithmic then all of this is
nothing compared to the to just reading
one block
how does the client know where to put
the one
like usually you don't know where the
block is
so the client reads the metadata so he
knows where every block is that's
essentially free that's essentially free
because the block size is big enough
that all of this little stuff is
irrelevant
yeah
okay so let me say a little about active
security so um in the case of oram
without server computation active
security is never a big deal most papers
don't talk about it or uh because
there's a generic way you can add it you
can generally protect against active
attacks by using merkle trees or memory
checking to authenticate each position
as you're reading you just so the client
would keep the hash of the merkle tree
just of all the data stored in the
server and every time he reads a
location from the server just checks
that he's getting the right value every
time he writes he would update the
markup tree accordingly so there's a
generic way
of protecting against active attacks in
the understanding without server
computation but what about onion ram
server computation you can't do that
because now you're instructing the
server to do complicated operations not
just write and read values on the on
storage
so one answer is you can solve this
using snarks assessing non-interactive
arguments of knowledge you can solve
everything with them they're very
powerful tool
unfortunately they're um
they're based on strong non-falsifiable
assumptions and they're not very
efficient in practice uh
at least not yet
so uh we have another answer a very
simple way to do this no new assumptions
and realistically efficient
um for this particular scheme
the idea consists of really two
components so one is um we're going to
protect the metadata with the merkle
tree so we're going to use that solution
on the metadata which you do actually
read and write to one bit at a time
you're not doing any complicated
operations on that
but the actual data which you're not
just reading and writing directly sort
of instructing the server to do stuff on
it we're going to have a different
solution that are called verification
chunks so let me tell you what that is
so i want to think of each encrypted
block as consisting of a bunch of chunks
q chunks chunks are relatively small q
is relatively big okay
and
a homomorphic select operation just
prefer
uh operates independently on each chunk
position so whenever you do this like
homomorphic operation to to
uh to select one of these blocks you're
just going to independently select one
of the chunks in this column the chunk
in this column
you know you're going to select the same
row in every column so you're going to
take one operation and perform it in
every column independently
and so here's the idea the idea will be
that the client will just take a random
subset of these chunks and store them in
the metadata
okay small small subset so constant size
or security parameter size
not enough to make a difference much
smaller than the whole block
and each time the client performs one of
the homomorphic select operations to
move data around he can actually
download these chunks these alcohol and
verification chunks that he's throwing
in the metadata and do that operation
manually himself on these chunks so he's
doing the same thing the server is doing
but not on the whole block just on some
small subset of these chunks
it's very much like cut and choose right
and so every and then whenever the
client actually reads a block from the
server he can check that the chunks in
those positions are correct because he
has those in the metadata he's done
everything on the manual himself
okay so uh this pretty much works um of
course here if the server cheats on a
random position you're not that likely
to catch him you have some small chance
of catching him but not that high but we
can amplify this by using error
correcting codes
okay so this solution with our
correcting codes gets you
to get active
monitor security with verification
queries
uh so um
no uh but we don't that i so in some
sense it's not as much of a problem here
because anyway this is uh there's sort
of one server and if he cheats you you
know you you stop
you have to stop
so what kind of security do you get like
you don't get normal ability or
something like this right i mean you do
uh you you make sure that uh
every time you you perform a read you
get the right value out the one that
should be written there and even if the
server is active you can't break your
privacy
so
enact you get both the active active
privacy and correctness
is this a generic memory checking uh or
are
how is it combined or specific to
no it's actually pretty specific i mean
i'm using the fact that there's a big
block and you're doing sort of operating
on the doing the same operation on every
chunk of that block independent list so
it's not a very generic solution
but it is related to some concepts some
of these solutions from verifiable
computation uh some of these cut and
choose techniques that give any set
okay
so uh the punchline here is that we get
active security essentially for free
just with this solution you don't need
any new assumptions or any really neat
tricks
how many chunks will they build for
because he has to read these chunks
right over the server also previously
there was only one no but it's not a
multiplicative right it's an additive
polylock so it doesn't actually change
the synthetics
you're saying is just
the encryption is so this blocks so
think of the blocks that's pretty big
and you're storing like very few bits or
small chunks of these blocks in the
metadata
so this doesn't really asymptotically
have much of an impact
just a comment so in in in my original
oram
because i knew exactly when i'm writing
any memory location you can just
timestamp and sign everything so you
don't even need miracle trees good point
yeah malicious security without miracles
yes yes so because and then trio ram as
well because things are already stored
in a tree merkle trees essentially for
free because it's already in a tree
structure
but but i yeah i'm ignoring these uh
yeah so it's polylock factors achieve a
similar effect by just changing the
problem like doing the public thing on a
modified program somebody what previous
thing
the original i think without the
verification just the merkle tree
no no
we know we're not going to do nothing
okay but uh
or maybe only on the
later data
but but they modifying the the program
in a way that essentially
emulate these
this this notification i'm not sure i i
don't i don't think so
at least i don't see it
okay
so um so that let that that's all i want
to say about uh about onion ore and the
punch line is you can get very small
bandwidth okay small communication
overhead if the block size are big
enough let me now move on to the next
part guar built carbon ram
okay how much time do i have uh
let's say
25 more minutes okay great
so uh garbodram is an analog of garbled
circuits that work in the ramp setting
it was an idea that was
introduced by uh lou and ostrovsky both
here
and the idea is that now the client will
take the entire program that he wants to
execute on this remote to store data in
some sense garble it okay do something
to it and produce this uh i'm gonna use
still does to denote garbage stuff so
produce this garbage program pitilda
he'll send that to the server and the
server can execute it on the on this on
the memory on the outsource memory and
give and create and get the output back
that he can send back to the client
okay um
the cost of garbling here and the size
of this garbled program and this
solution is as big as the running time
the ram runtime of the original program
so the client isn't saving any work he's
running the program himself but he
doesn't have the data he's sort of doing
the work of running the program himself
without knowing the data
creates this garbage program then this
sends it to server the server knows the
data and can actually execute it so
there's no saving of work the client is
doing all the work of running the
program we're saving on rounds
instead of like
running the program by doing each read
independently by executing some protocol
with the server we're doing it all in
one go one shot
okay so i'll let me give you a slightly
better definition with a slightly
different picture of a client so here we
have two algorithms uh there's an
algorithm that garbles data so it takes
some data and a key came creates the
garbo data that's what you outsource to
the server
that's sort of the pre-processing of the
data that's what you saw on the server
and then you can garble various programs
p i'm thinking of all the inputs the
program is being hard-coded in the
program itself so you're going to
somehow garble a program that you want
to run with the whatever input you want
to run it at
send it to the server and the server
will be able to evaluate this garbage
program by
using memory access to garbo data i want
to mention these programs you can do
this many times you can garble many many
programs on the same data
okay so think of it as many different
database queries
these
programs can actually write to the data
they can both read and write okay these
are read write programs
and so the order in which they're
executed matters right it's not the same
as executing one first and second one
second versus flipping it because these
are writing to the data so here when the
client garbles this program he also has
the index i the order in which they're
garbled and the server can only execute
them in that order
okay so the security property
is that the server will only learn the
outputs of these programs the y one y
two y three the outputs and nothing else
and these are the outputs if you ran the
program in the correct order programs in
the correct order
i mean doesn't matter almost a circus so
he was addressing is
related with strictly weaker problems
that he would just first garble a
circuit and then quickly can do garbling
of each input so it's exactly the same
data and program
yeah so so far
this looks like garbage circuit the main
difference is going to be the efficiency
considerations which i'm going to tell
you in a second
so first of all let me tell you about
the efficiency and then maybe if things
aren't clear you'll ask again so uh
garbling the data should take just time
proportion to the size of the data
and this hotel does hiding glock factors
and also security parameter factors so
i'm gonna ignore those
and uh garbling the program should take
time proportional to the ram runtime of
the program as well as evaluating the
program should take time proportional to
ram runtime of the program so for
example this program could be a binary
search query
and then garbling it would be pretty
efficient as would executing it
just time proportionate to minus search
even though this data is huge
does that answer your question okay well
i mean i understand that you can
straighten ramps i'm just kind of
curious so if it was garbled circuit for
a second
the main thing is that you can do that
the previous thing wouldn't do right so
you are swapping none of the problems
right so previous that's right
and there were like multiple inputs that
you can
but efficiency was much faster than the
inputs but the input is just
proportional to so previously let me
just say previously i could have done
this where this was proportional to the
circuit size of the program execution
there then the ram runtime so if it was
a database query like a sql query it
would be proportional to whole database
not the binary search right not log
that's the difference the difference is
the efficiency
you could have done this reusable stuff
as well that's not
that this like running many programs
okay
good so is the security and is that
clear the security goal here
okay
uh so uh we can relax security a little
bit it'll be useful to actually look at
a weaker security where we're gonna say
it's okay if this uh if this garbled
program actually reveals or
if we reveal even the contents of the
data we're not gonna try to hide the
contents of the data and even we're not
gonna try to hide the data access panel
but that's the only thing you learn you
don't learn anything else about the
program other than its data access
pattern and the data that it's accessing
okay so that sounds like a lot weaker
here i'm revealing the locations of the
memory that are accessing each step i'm
revealing the values that are read and
written to memories each step it sounds
like a lot weaker
but the great news is that's good enough
if you can do this you can get the full
thing how just compile the program with
oblivious ram take whatever program you
would have executed it compile it with
oblivious ram so now run the program
that would use oblivious run to read the
data so even if you see the data access
pattern of the compiled program you
don't learn anything about what the
original program was doing
okay
so this is a generic solution so it's
good enough to focus on this weak
security
what is hidden the program
just the program yeah whatever inputs it
has whatever secret keys it has all
that's hidden you just learned the data
that it's reading and writing and the
access
pattern okay so we can focus on this
weak securing notion and so let me give
you an overview of the garbo dram
construction of lou and ostrovsky so
it's really a beautiful scheme um and
for now i want to focus
make my life even easier i just want to
focus on read-only computations assume
the program just reads never writes to
the database to the data okay read-only
so before i tell you how to do this how
to garbage program let's look at sort of
ram program execution without garbling
without security okay so this is uh i
want to think of a ram computation i
want to think of the data in memory just
each uh memory cell has one bit
so for here let's consider just bits
and i want to think of the program
execution is being really specified by
some very simple cpu step circuit like
that's actually what's cool you know
what your laptop is doing there's a cpu
it's some sort of a pretty small size
circuit the circuit gets some state you
can think of it as
the various registers things like that
it does a little bit of computation and
then it says okay i want to read this
location you go in the map you go in the
memory you read that location you put it
on this wire there's a special read bid
wire on the on the next execution and
then execute that circuit again
so i'm sort of unrolling it but there's
really one cpu step circuit this is this
this circuit and the circuit are the
same
okay and this is how i want to think of
a ram execution so you can think of the
initial state as specifying whatever uh
some hard-coded values in the program
like some small input to the program or
you can think of what really happens
the actual code of the program would be
written in memory right that's what
really happens so you can do that here
okay so how are we going to garble this
so the way we're going to garble this is
we're going to just take each of these
cpu step circuits and garble them one by
one independently so even though it's
all the same circuit we're going to
garble it many times
how many times as many times as the
number of steps the computation takes
okay we're going to run in time
proportion to computation
and the state of the circuit is just
going to be garbled and travel from one
circuit to the next it's going to remain
garbled
on these these wires are going to remain
garbled you can't really see them
okay and in addition it's just going to
output the read location in the clears
okay because we're willing to reveal the
locations that you're reading
at this point
so that's gonna be the garble program
i'm gonna say a little more about in a
sec it's not exactly it but almost
how are we going to garble the data
so in each location i want to give you
some sort of a key that depends on the
data in that location
and the way we're going to do it is uh
we're just going to prf key f sub k and
if the data bid in location one is a one
we're gonna give you fk of one one
otherwise fk one zero so we're gonna
give you prf of the location and the bid
in that location so in each location you
have either pf of i z or i one there's
two values you could have in each
location depending on the data there
okay so what's the problem the problem
is you can start executing this garbage
circuit right that's fine and then it
says okay you should read like the bid
in this location so you read it great
now you need to put some value on this
wire what value do you put you need to
the label for this wire
okay now ideally i would put that in the
data but i don't know or i would make
the like
the label of this wire be the same as
the value here
right the two labels would be the two
possible values here the problem is when
i'm creating these circuits at compile
time or when i'm creating this carbon
program i don't know what data is going
to be read i don't know what locations
are going to be accessed that's only
going to decide it at runtime so i don't
know how to do that
so i don't know how to make the label
here match the one here
and the goal will be to somehow
translate between them so i want to
somehow be able to translate between the
keys i could have here for the two bits
zero and one with the two labels i
should put on this wire here
and the way to do that so this really
nice idea is we're going to put a prf
key
in the garbage circuits so the garbage
circuits will have a prf key hard code
in them and they're going to transl
compute
some sort of a translation table that
lets you translate between the data in
the in in memory and the labels of this
wire
okay so they're going to put two
encryptions of the labels for these wire
labels here on label one under the two
possible values you could have in memory
in that location the point is this
translation table is created at runtime
it's created by the circuit at runtime
when it knows what location you're going
to be reading in that i step
you don't know this information at
compile time you can't just give it out
ahead of time but the circuit can create
it at runtime
okay so that's it that's the solution uh
so you know you would read the value in
memory decrypt one of these two
ciphertext and then get the right bit
for this wire and be able to execute the
next circuit
okay
so let's try to prove security and
something subtle happens so i want to
say that if you see this whole you know
all these garbage circuit and the garbo
data you don't learn anything other than
the output of the computation at the
very end
so the good news is okay the first
garbage circuit you just get like this
initial garbage state so you can think
of that as like some stuff that's hard
coded in the in the beginning of the
computation just to get it started
so you get some garbled value here
you don't learn by the security of the
garbage circuit you don't learn anything
other than the output okay so all you
learn are these two ciphertexts
and the labels for the next next state
now let's assume that let's say in
memory at location i there's the the bid
one so you can decrypt the label one
okay
now i want to use the security of the
second i want to rely on the secure of
this garbage circuit so you don't learn
anything from that other than its output
now if you think about intuitively
that's true because you don't have label
zero you only have one label for each of
these wires and that's exactly what
from benny stock that's exactly what
garbage circuits tell you if you only
have one label for each wire you don't
learn anything other than the output
so there's something subtle which is the
label for the other bit is you do have
it encrypted
you have it encrypted under some value
some prf value fk of i0 and this prf key
is stored in this circuit
okay so ideally i'd like to say that
this ciphertext is secure you shouldn't
be able to decrypt it you know and
intuitively you can't
but in order to do that in order to say
that you can't decrypt the ciphertext i
need to rely on the secure of the
encryption or the prf key this key k
but this key case included in this
garbage circuit and in order to argue
that you don't learn that prf key i need
to use the secure of the garbot circuit
right so i'm stuck
i don't know how to prove this and
there's a circularity problem here we
don't have a good proof for it
so for technical reasons it's
rectangular on the slide circular
problem
so is it secure is there an actual
problem we don't know actually probably
for natural schemes you won't find an
attack
sounds secure but also we don't know how
to prove it and there's no really nice
assumption other than just yeah you can
assume the whole thing is secure that
would let me prove it i don't know any
simple assumption
so can we fix it
and the idea is yes there's been a
series of works proposing various fixes
for this problem
uh so um
uh so one fix is to use identity based
encryption i'll show you actually that's
the fix i'm gonna tell you how to do i'm
gonna show you that one that's probably
the simplest one
so unfortunately though you need
stronger assumptions for garbage
circuits we just need one-way functions
now you need identity-based encryption
turns out there's actually better ways
to do just with one way function so
in this work we showed how to do it with
one way functions but didn't get quite
poly logarithmic overhead got something
into the epsilon and then there's a
really beautiful work that's coming up
at this stock is that right at the stock
that shows how to get even the poly
logarithmic overhead
and it's based on different techniques
than the first sticks so it somehow uses
uh just one-way functions and prfs but
again the problem was that these prf
keys were hard-coded in all the circuits
so here you're somehow going to have an
evolving key and make sure that the
value that you need to protect the
ciphertext in each step is not contained
in any future circuit that's really the
main idea
but it's doing it is tricky
it's really nice work and
another fix actually that fixes more
than just this problem is even in the
solution i showed you if you thought if
you think about it
it needed you need it to garble a
circuit that evaluates a prf
okay
right and that's a non-black box use of
a prf that's sort of an inefficient
thing you're using one-way functions and
not black box way and so there's a
really nice work uh recent work by
garcon ostrovsky that shows how to solve
this with just black box use of a pr so
you're not evaluating a pr inside a
garbage circuit or anything like that
so again it seems seems difficult if you
think about what we were doing so far so
i'm just going to show you the simplest
thing identity based encryption sounds
complicated because ib's complicated
that's actually the simplest way to do
this and the idea is you know what what
was the problem we were encrypting
things and the decryption key was
hard-coded in various garbage circuits
so let's not you know let's use public
instead of symmetric encryption
instead of so we don't we shouldn't have
to hard code the public infuse you know
the the value hardcore in the circuits
would just be a public key not a secret
key
seems like a simple enough problem right
so we would just hardcore public keys in
the garbage circuits that way they can
still encrypt stuff but now they can
decrypt it so you get security
the caveat is you actually turns out you
need identity based encryption not just
regular public encryption by
identity-based public encryption and i
want to show you that even the original
solution that i i showed you on the
previous slide a good way of seeing it
is as using some sort of an
identity-based symmetric encryption
which you can just build from prfs
i'm going to show you that so
identity-based encryption has a short
master public key that lets you encrypt
any identity you want and there's secret
keys for various identities
so this is the solution i already showed
you i didn't change anything this is the
picture you saw before
and i want to reinterpret it as using
symmetricy identity-based encryption so
i want to think of each of these values
in the garble memories as various secret
keys for identities
so in each location i you would have a
secret key for the for the identity
either i zero or i one depending on the
bid in that location
okay so i want to think of these as sort
of secret key identity based secret keys
and what what is this stuff well this is
real and identity based encryption a
symmetric key one that encrypts to the
identities i comma zero and i comma once
the labels labels urine label one
respectively
okay and what's the what's this thing
it's a master secret key that lets you
encrypt because this is a symmetric
encryption
so now let's use a public encryption
what happens nothing really changes just
we replace the master secret key with
the master public key so now i'm
changing the notation but these will
still be secret keys for identities you
know i comma zero comma one i'm just
going to write it this way
uh these will be just
identity public key encryptions to the
identities i0 and i1 and now the
circuits have a hard-coded master
publicly and this breaks the circularity
right because this cipher text cannot be
decrypted even if you know all the stuff
hard coded in in the other circuits
okay so that was read-only computation
how do we allow rights do we have enough
time to allow rights
uh
seven minutes
okay right in seven minutes i'll uh
so i'll say something uh short
let me even skip this so uh the main
idea will be that uh the garbled memory
now will still have identity based
secret keys but the identity will also
have some sort of time period associated
with it so it's not just the location
number but the time period j so the
secret keys in each location will be uh
secret keys for identity j ib where i is
the location j is the last time that
location was written to and b is the bit
in that location that was that was
written in that time period
and so to read the location i to read
any location
i just need to encrypt this identity
okay so i need to know the last time
that location was written to and let me
just tell you that's not a problem and
leave it at that okay
uh you can do that
and so okay so to read the location we
can just encrypt these two identities
like we did before
to write to a location though i need to
create a secret key
for that time period right to write in
time period j to location i need to
create the secret key in order to create
a secret key it seems like i would need
to have the master secret key in the
circuits
right and that would reintroduce
circularity
so can you fix that turns out that yes
the idea would be to have some sort of a
restricted secret key in each circuit at
time period j that can only create
secret keys for these identities like
that start with a j but not for others
okay and this prevents the circular
security because the cipher text that
any cpu step creates can't be decrypted
by future cpu steps they only have
weaker secret keys or different masters
you could get that don't allow you to
decrypt this stuff
so let me just say that because i want
to um okay let me let me skip to
skip this part that's the high level of
idea how to do rights
that lets you do the everything
so that that gives you a solution for
the garbage ramp program
so i just wanted to mention uh i think
evgeny has that so this if you compare
this solution to what we are doing just
by using oblivious ram to interact with
the server the one difference here is
the server actually learns the output y
right he gets it in the clear
so is that a problem and what about
malicious server maybe he sends you the
wrong why can you actually be sure that
you're getting the right value i'm
claiming you can fix both these problems
very easily in one go instead of
garbling the program p that just outputs
some value y
garbler program p prime that has a
hard-coded
secret key k and outputs an
authenticated encryption of y so now the
server does learn
why prime when he executes this garbled
program but that doesn't tell him
anything about why and in fact you can
even check that you're getting the right
answer back because it's an
authenticated encryption
randomness for this indicated encryption
it's hard in the program think of it as
a as a it could even be a one-time uh
deterministic encryption needs local
randomness to produce those no it is a
one-time one-time encryption so yeah you
don't need any
random id for example you need
randomness
uh yeah you could have a pr there
okay
um yeah
good so let me just briefly mention the
last part it was planned to be brief
anyway so uh i want to talk about
sustain garbage ramps and the setting
the picture looks exactly the same as
the last part so what changes
uh one more efficiency requirement so
here i don't want the client to do
almost any work to garbler program so
creating this garbled program p
should take time that only depends on
the code size of this program not the
running time okay so it's a lazy client
he's not doing the work the server is
doing all the work
so uh the picture looks pretty much the
same as what we had before just the
really the thing that changed was before
this was uh garbling the program the
efficiency of that was proportionate to
ram runtime now it's just proportional
to the code size
and again the code size you don't have
to take it literally as being the code
it could just be whatever you need like
if it's a database query whatever search
term you need to specify the query the
code could really live in inside the
memory
okay so whatever you need to specify the
program you're you're executing
so um
beautiful thing there's been a lot a
series of recent works showing how to do
this based on indistinguishable
obfuscation so unfortunately we do need
at this point we seem to need more
powerful tools like uh
non-succinct version we just knew how to
do from one way functions here we're
using much heavier machinery but we get
this amazing property so there's been a
series of works doing this i don't want
to say too much about each one uh but
the good news is that uh the last few
works meet exact so most of these meet
like some small variant of the goal as i
said it the last few works actually meet
the goal exactly
um there's actually some differences so
this work meets it where the amount of
to garble the data
you need to spend time proportional to
not just the actual data you're garbling
but the max amount of memory that you'll
ever use
whereas the last two words
the last two works actually let you even
do it let you do it in time proportion
to just the amount of data you're
garbling
okay so this makes sense even if you
initially start out with no data
outsource the server and some of these
programs will write some data as they're
being executed
you can do that whereas
in this work yet actually know how much
memory you're going to need ahead of
time
many of these works actually even
achieve indistinguishable obfuscation
for rams from i o for circuit so you get
even more
so that's sort of a side benefit of what
they do and i want to say it's actually
some of the techniques are also related
to work on garbling turing machines so
even though the settings are a little
different and this dog is about rams i
don't want to talk about turing machines
the techniques are somewhat related
so let me tell you just very very you
know high level intuition something
about what's going on so here's the
naive way or the the naive way that you
would try to solve this problem if you
were seeing it you would say well let me
just take this cpu step circuit that we
were garbling many times before you know
we were garbling it once you know for
every time step of the computation
instead of doing that let me just
obfuscate it once
so i'm just going to give you an
obfuscated cpu step circuit
well a little more than that so it's a
cpu step circuit that gets uh the state
encrypted the state from the previous
step encrypted and also the read bit
whatever it read from the garbo data
also encrypted
and inside it would just do the
decryption do some small computation and
then
output the bit that it's reading for the
next step the bit that it's writing
the encryption of the video is writing
and the encrypted state for the next
step and then you can keep executing
this just by feeding this next state to
itself and keep going
okay so that's the intuition of what you
should do
of course this isn't good enough you
need to use oram and memory checking to
ensure that the data is private you know
that
for example the the access pattern
doesn't you know the same reason we need
ram all the time that you need to make
sure that the access pattern which you
do get here in the clear doesn't reveal
anything about the actual access pattern
of the computation
and you also need to make use some
memory checking at the very least to
make sure that you're getting the right
values as you're as you're reading these
bits
so this seems intuitive enough it's like
such a simple scheme like how hard can
it be to prove this so it turns out if
you think about it it's actually very
hard it turns out to be very hard to
prove it but the amazing thing is that
with uh some special oram schemes very
specially designed one special design
memory checking special design
encryption and many other tricks and
about 60 to 160 pages worth of proof
so i think that's uh that's pretty much
what those papers the range that they
fall into
uh you can prove this assuming
indistinguishable obfuscation so it
seems so simple but really very very
tricky to get this right
but achieve something really amazing
so i want to stop there so just some
conclusions we saw that if you have orm
with server computation by introducing
server computation you can get some nice
benefits like reducing the bandwidth
reducing the round complexity even
getting completely non-interactive
solutions
and reducing the client computation in
the very last step where the client does
no work pretty much no work at all and
the server does all the work
many open questions so better lower or
upper bounds on o-ram without server
computation
um
showing
getting a constant communication
overhead o-ramp's a variant of the
onion-o-ram scheme i showed you from
simpler assumptions not necessarily
homomorphic encryption maybe one-way
functions why not
um
simplify these
60-160 page works uh the sustain garbo
grand schemes
and
maybe the the most interesting question
can sustain garbled ram be done without
i o it doesn't seem to inherently imply
it can you do it without it
so uh let me leave up here thank you
a few quick
okay
for the last question uh when what goes
wrong need to try to use like a reusable
global carbon circuit instead of i o
yeah it's a great question so uh
reusable garbage it seems like it should
work the main problem is that in
reusable garbage circuits the garbled
input
has to always be bigger than the output
and if you think about it here you're
like feeding the garbled output into
itself as a garbled input so the lengths
never work out
seems like a small thing
but it actually completely kills the
solution i mean if you use simulation
security but you don't have to write
well but ex and that's what those 62 i
guess that's what those papers are sort
of implicitly doing right somehow saying
you don't actually need to
exactly have a garbage circuit with
stimulation for each step
there's always a fresh little garbage
circuit given out which is smaller than
the actual computation so there is no
hope for sort of repetition in that
sense so for every input right
that's small
much smaller than the computation itself
so if you're giving away oh what do you
mean for every input there's the first
garbot circuit so the reusable variable
circuit right for the you do the
computation using that
the reuse part for it for but for every
computation you have to give a smaller
global circuit to do the decryption at
the end so that part it has to be sort
of provided every time
that makes itself sometimes
one thing i think the idea would be to
just take this whatever you were using
obfuscation you create one garbage
circuit but the problem is that here the
garbled input the output should be a
garbled input to itself and we need the
garbage input to be strictly bigger than
the output so this doesn't work
that's pretty much it in fact the the
length would grow expo you know
a
exponentially
suggestion it's not a
you could do something very heuristic
but it's it's um
you would need to opt you you need to
garble random oracle
right so that's sort of
so so it's sort of you could do it under
assumptions that are known to be false
and in that sense but heuristically it
seems like it could work yeah
can't you just use the underwater in
order to compress your uh
um
not clear not not clear not clear we
don't have so there there have been
proposed solutions that did some
reusable garbage circuits with this
right efficiency but they did need to
garble the random article i don't know
of any solution that didn't need to do
that
good
okay yeah i i don't know i don't know
how to do it without with you know it's
it's plausible i don't see any
possibility but but either way the the
the basic security property we need to
assume on the basic thing that it's
simulation we would know is false
okay but heuristically the whole thing
could work i agree
no you could result in
distinguishability what do you mean
no that's very hard i don't know how to
compose and distinguish i mean
yeah so even if you had
indistinguishability based um
uh
garbled circuits
i don't know how to
that's essentially what those works are
somewhat doing implicitly but it that
that's not easy to do it's not easy to
use and distinguishably based
definitions to get the full goal at the
end
just indistinguishability based
definitions don't compose nicely and
here you're iterating things that's the
main problem
so
is there any part of your presentation
that they
can be practical
the server aided
over
the onion ram i think could be practical
for big enough block sizes and if you
really were in a setting where you care
about bandwidth much more than the
amount of computation server does
because in contrast to regular ram here
the server is doing some
fairly light but additively homomorphic
encryption operations which you know
it's much better than fhe but still it's
it's heavier than just uh
uh you know symmetric key crypto which
basically ram was doing but if you
really care about bandwidth much more
than computation then yes this could be
and in some settings you might then that
that could be practical
okay so let's thank daniel again